hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today I'm gonna
be taking you through another game from
the world rapid championship of course
the world rappin championship this year
was won by the one and only Magnus
Carlsen and today I wanted to walk you
through one of his victories with black
against Levon Aronian now this was a
very interesting game with some new
ideas in the opening and some
unfortunate blunders as well so why
don't we just take a look and see what
happens Levon started with d4 we saw
Knight f6 c4 e6 that f3 d5 just a Queens
gambit declined structure Knight c3 and
now c5 and this is the semi tirage and
this structure with c4 d for c5 and d5
is a very it's one full of tension and
this tension actually shouldn't last too
too long in the opening one specific
characteristic of the structure is that
you generally end up in what's called an
isolated Queens pawn position and will
very quickly see this happen after C
takes d5 and E takes d5 so immediately
White has the option to capture on c5
and you would now see the isolated
Queens pawn position this Queens pawn on
d5 has no friends to help it out so it's
isolated and these positions can be very
very double-edged White has a weakness
to attack because no pawns can defend
the d5 pawn meanwhile black would have
an edge in space the central space can
be used to activate his pieces a little
bit more freely and that's generally the
character of of these positions from the
semi tirage in this case though first of
all white shouldn't capture right away
he would rather wait for black to waste
some time with this Bishop before taking
on c5 or wait for black to commit to
developing some other pieces so instead
white plays useful moves g3 we see
knight c6 hitting the D pawn Bishop g2
and now C takes d4 black is the one who
caves first and we still get this
isolated Queens pawn position and now we
see Bishop c5 which
is not the main move it should be seven
is a bit more common but this is by no
means anything new and here white has
exclusively played the move Knight be
three keeping this deep on isolated
gaining some time on this Bishop and
historically the game has gone pretty
naturally black moves the bishop forward
white gets castled develops his pieces
this Bishop can come to e3 this rook
maybe
maneuvers its way to d2 and puts more
pressure along the D file this actually
though has not been you know too
successful for white black usually
manages to equalize of course the
isolated Queens pawn position while
double-edged is still usually balanced
in positions like these so it's not like
White has has a crushing advantage so in
this game Aronian came up with the new
idea which has not been played of
playing Knight takes c6 and I call this
a new idea the idea of taking the knight
on c6 and the iqp
isolated queen pawns positions has been
known and you transfer into what's
called a hanging pawn structure and so
this pawn on c6 supports the pawn on d5
for the moment but actually both of
these pawns can become weak if black
isn't careful we'll just get through
some more developing moves first though
castles castles and now white plays the
move Queen c2 which is deceptively
annoying generally we don't see Queen c2
as a very threatening move but in this
case it really is eyeing this c6 pawn
and if black plays a nonchalant move
let's say h6 stopping a pin already
white would be completely crushing with
a move like Knight a four and Queen
takes c6 coming on the board you see how
these pawns can very very quickly become
weak so of course Magnus has made a
tougher stuff than that
he plays Bishop e6 removing his Bishop
from the threat of Knight a4 white
actually continues with Knight a 4
anyways keeping an eye on this c5 square
this is a great way to play against the
structure if you can prevent this pawn
from coming to c5 it's going to be very
very awkward for the black pieces to get
active for example this Bishop would
love to come here place c5 play d4 trade
off White's bish
on the long diagonal and then really not
have any problems at all with his
position in this case though he has to
choose the slightly more awkward Bishop
d7 this bishop isn't totally happy on d7
and likely blacks gonna have to waste
some more time moving this piece again
white continues with b3 aiming to
develop his bishop on the other long
diagonal we see rook e8 putting some
pressure on the on black staff open file
Bishop b2 very natural black throws in
this move
h5 threatening to create some some
trouble on the Kings side white responds
to the natural age for and now we see 94
once again keeping an eye on this c5
square you definitely don't want to
allow a knight to land here
of course Knight c5 wouldn't be such a
good move here right away because of the
weakness of this epon if not for this
upon weakness 95 is a very common idea
to really pin down the weakness here on
on c6 but ok we see h4 94 now e3 puts
this pawn on the square roots defended
kind of stunts this Bishop a little bit
you see rook c8 and now white changes
the structure once again with Knight
takes b6 and pawn takes b6
and here white actually plays a very
very clever move and so if you at home
think you can find a way to win upon I
dare you to try you can pause the video
here and see if you can come up with the
move that LaVon played to actually get a
slight slight edge in this game okay
with that in minds hopefully you found
it it's Queen d1 and this is a very
strange-looking move it's taking
advantage of the fact that black heads
push this pawn to h5 and you might think
well well what's what's the big deal I
can defend this pawn any number of ways
right you know I have Bishop g4 I have
Knight f6 I have pawn g6 but all of
these moves actually run into some
trouble and so in fact Magnus chooses
just to jettison this pawn just to throw
it away in exchange for some central
play but let's take a look and see
what's wrong with these moves
if Jesus
the fact is you're weakening this
diagonal just just a bit too much
something like Queen d4 is going to be
very very awkward to deal with you can't
really stop this this from coming
through you can play a move f6 but now
I'll simply take your bishop
or take your knight rather with my
bishop and I'll be winning upon so g6 is
out Knight f6 is a similar story I'll
still capture this Knight and then
capture your pawn and then Bishop g4 is
the complex complex one
perhaps Magnus could have gone for this
of course the problem is f3 appears to
be a fork of course this isn't quite so
simple though because black is getting
some counter play by taking on g3 and
for one you could capture this rook on
f1 but also you can get some some very
dangerous play around the king by simply
taking h4 with the Queen White has a lot
of pieces hanging and this would have
been a very very active way for Magnus
to try to play instead of going for
these complications though Magnus simply
plays Bishop f5 and after Queen takes h5
picking up the pawn Queen d7 you see
some threats on the light squares and
black is going to look to to play in the
center so we see Queen d1 black
continues with c5 simply rook e1
bringing the rooks into the center rook
cd8 is black choice rook see one Bishop
h3 as always this Bishop is a very
important defender around the White King
and now Magnus simply looks to trade it
off Queen f3 is played and Magnus
chooses f6 which is a little bit
abnormal but it's not completely wrong
here he just wants to stunt this Bishop
on b2 we see Bishop takes h3 Queen takes
h3 and now rook cd1 so this is the weak
pond in White's camp so white or in
blacks camp rather so white is going to
look to pile up on this pawn and that's
how he intends to win the game he wants
to open up the center force things to be
kind of traded off and then I'll simply
have an extra H pawn in any endgame that
he goes into of course chess is not
always so simple
and magnus carlsen is kind of a master
at keeping his his cool even when you
know the end games aren't favorable for
him
so he simply you know keeps the tension
plays b5 and he's forcing white to make
more moves and that's that's the nasty
thing about playing Magnus he gives you
no easy decisions and so white can do
any number of things here in the game he
chose to play Queen g2 offering up a
trade Magnus keeps pieces on the board
we see f3 this night simply drops back
to d6 and now white starts expanding on
the Kings side and while this isn't such
a bad idea it is what led to lavon's
eventual demise by expanding on the
Kings side you are accession your
majority making this H pawns presence
kind of felt you know you eventually
might play it in h6 and then this Bishop
can really shine but the downside of
course whenever you push your pawns
forward you're weakening your King and
this is the problem that LaVon
eventually ran into Magnus chose this
moment to push d4 of course II takes d4
might actually be met with the Queen
sacrifice Queen takes a one gaining two
rooks for the Queen and really breaking
open open this King that would be
horrible for white so instead we see
Queen c2 no we don't see Queen c2 we see
Queen d2 keeping the tension here for
just a moment and defending the rook so
this is now a threat we see Queen d5 and
the idea is that now there's already
some pressure on this f3 pawn and you
can start to see the air around the
white King and you can start to see how
how this game can kind of go wrong for
white it's a very dangerous position
LaVon still had it under control though
you play as a takes d4 and now black
could in theory go ahead and capture
this F pawn but White's planning to play
the simple Queen g2 trying to evict this
Queen and then D takes e5 and this would
be totally fine for white actually and
we're getting closer to the type of
endgame that white is really looking for
right now this past C pawn is going to
be very very dangerous on
can unless black can pick it up
immediately and so Magnus chose not to
go in for this line instead of playing
Queen takes f3 and allowing this pawn to
get to the dangerous e5 square magnus
plays c4 an idea just to keep this pawn
on d4 keep this bishop locked out of the
game for the moment and try ends you
know hamper the white pieces and this is
where everything kind of went wrong for
Aronian and it's actually a very very
strange mistake that he made it's very
very natural now you know before you
were tactically defending your f3 pawn
because you had the threat of taking on
c5 Black has removed this threat so it's
very natural now should just defend your
pawn just play a move King f2 even king
g2 although it's a bit less natural
I like King f2 just defending f3 and now
you can go about you know your business
in your own time black might be
regaining a pond over on the Queen side
but white or white should stand better
in this endgame due to this very nice
Bishop and white is still upon up onto
the good you can imagine a move like d5
coming later and like I said h5 h6
coming through to shake loose blacks
Kings side but instead of that some of
the very natural king f2 or King g2 we
see the move Bishop a3 and this is just
very very strange it simply loses this
pawn on f3 white still has this move
Queen g2 to keep things a little bit
under control but now with f3 gone
blacks problems are really really
nowhere to be found
the game continued where it takes you
one where it takes you one Queen c3 the
rook is attacked comes back to d1 and
now we see b4 from AG Magnus and this
Bishop has actually seen much better
days Queenie e3 check was mangas choice
LaVon chose to block this piece off with
Queen H Queen f2 after Queen h3 Queen g2
we see a quick repetition and now this
Queen comes to e4
once again attacking this pawn so Queen
g2 we see again and now c3
and you can really feel the the power of
blacks position here
well material is still in whites favor
it is 5 pounds 2 for this c3 pawn is
worth more than any pawn on the board
for for white so Bishop c1 is what white
played perhaps white should have taken
the opportunity to trade the Queen's
although the endgame does also look
quite bad this pawn comes up to c2 now
and after rook f1 white is picking up
yet another pawn and now our black is
picking up yet another pawn and now with
material even the C pawn will will tell
the story of this game we see some more
checks gaining some time and now g5 is
why it's choice Queen e5 check King age
1 and now Magnus played rook d1 which is
totally winning black is totally winning
here but perhaps it would have been a
bit easier to play the very very simple
rook d4 just picking up this this age
pawn
there's no good way to defend this pawn
if you play let's see there's nothing
you really can't play if you try to take
c2 you're simply going to get checkmated
after uh after something like this the
rook will come to h4 and hit this King
on h1 and there's nothing really to be
done so you can't take c2 you can't
really defend this pawn any other way
I'll simply just pick it up like this
and that would kind of spell the end of
the game instead though we see rook d1
and now white plays this move g6 and
you're starting to feel some some
pressure around the black King as well
lavon's starting to try and find some
chances 98 was Magnus's choice and now
after Queen f3
Magnus once again makes an awkward
decision he plays rook takes f1 and this
one I really do think is quite a bad
choice I would have much preferred to
see the move rook d4 or even Queen d4
once again eyeing this weakness on h4
and this would really be the end of the
game for for LaVon had Magnus chosen to
do something like this instead
but after rook f1 things start to get a
little complicated
let me see Queenie four check King g2 or
a queen g2 black does take this pawn but
after some more checks it's a little
unclear how we're going to get rid of
this bishop on c1 with just this night
stuck all the way back on d8 and the
fact is while black should should be
better in this endgame he's by no means
winning anymore it's actually quite
difficult
LaVon plays very well he plays Queenie
for King f8 Queen takes before check
picking up a pawn King comes to e8 of
course you don't want to stay in this
corner where this pawn is going to allow
many checkmating ideas for White Queen
b5 check King e7 Queen c5 check King e6
and the king wants to come up the board
to the Queen where it can hopefully hide
behind it
to avoid this perpetual we see Queen see
it check canny 5 we actually see Bishop
b2 now from White King efore and now the
the last move of the game was played and
I'll bet you guys will never guess the
move that Levon Aronian played because
it's quite a shocker here this position
is actually a draw with best play it's
kind of funny actually
there is no definite perpetual for white
but what white can do is make use of the
fact that this night is so far out of
play and that these two pieces together
are enough to stop this pawn from
getting the c1 so what white can do is
while black is organizing his pieces I
can simply start pushing this a pawn and
the King can come forward but now if the
King steps too far forward it's going to
be a simple perpetual like like so so
instead black has to try you know tricky
things start giving checks but every
time black wastes a tempo we're going to
push this a pawn further down the board
and eventually black will be unable to
to create any any threats and while this
is very very difficult to find over the
board it's a lot better than the try
that Levon Aronian had which was to play
Queen b7 check
now I'll let you at home try and figure
out see if you can find some way to
refute this move I'll give you a hint
it's a free queen and this is the
unfortunate end to Levon Aronian z--
game against Magnus Carlsen which is
kind of a shame it was a very
well-played game by by both sides up
until just a couple lapses in judgment
by Levon Aronian and of course you can't
afford to do that against Magnus Carlsen
he will take advantage he did take
advantage and that is how he won this
game well thank you very much for
joining me once again for game review my
name is Caleb Denby and I'll see you in
the next one